боку ми знаємо що ті Кошти які
закладаються на армію сьогодні вони її
би величезною їй дуже потужною сумою
поза один трильйона але за звітом
рахункової палати складається ситуація
що насправді у відсотковому
співвідношенні на збройні сили України
чомусь виділяється менше ніж навіть
закладено на цей рік і оце дуже
стривожить якщо ви розрахунку на 2023
рік нам треба набагато більше так само
мене тривожить те що зараз замість того
щоби всіма можливими способами шукати
системи ППО е-е розробляти нові якісь
зразки запроваджувати випробовувати
відновлювати військово-промисловість у
нас Шалені кошти закладаються на дороги
і це на жаль не змінилося під час
крайнього розгляду правок до бюджету
майже усі депутатські правки були
відхилені Що більше Зокрема я піднімала
питання як має забезпечуватися 280 а
постанова Кабміну так звана АТО ВПО
виплата коштів на компенсацію житла тим
військовослужбовцям які є з окупованих
територій і які ще з 14-го року
захищають Українську державу втративши
все майно на жаль крайніх три роки
Нічого зараз їм не виплачується і зміни
до бюджету не були вкладені хоча
пропонувалося взяти із фінансування
офісу президента на які закладені досить
великі кошти так само є велика проблема
з фінансуванням компенсації родинам
загиблих з того що зараз на даний момент
є там закладено 325 млн грн а це означає
що в середньому 21 родина хіба отримує
компенсацію а решта що робити на жаль у
нас загиблі вимірюється тисячами і ось
оці от речі Вони якось не співрозмірні
але мене ще в цьому контексті вразило те
що міністр фінансів не знав цих
найважливіших цифр і коли йому депутати
з трибуни це вказували він ну тобто так
посміхався роблячи вигляд що ми дурні а
насправді критична ситуація якщо міністр
фінансів цього не як він може
контролювати ті чи інші розкладки по
бюджету ми будемо мати надію щодо
опрацювання до другого читання Вони
якось мало би вирішуватися але на жаль
Все не так легко як би хотілося